hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another try not to
laugh challenge now I know in the past
I've done very poorly at this but this
time I've taken measures to make sure
that I don't ever ever laugh or yet
again feel joy inside of my soul so with
that being said I'm ready to get started
on this what have you got for me in this
day and age where joy is not existing
inside my body the world is funny not
funny boy the easy way to say ye is to
say
yeah oh it's too early for this no not
funny I do that on my own
- I scream into random objects that I
find on the street people don't think
I'm funny
I can do that too you know let me smash
[Music]
that's not funny at all why am i
laughing at that that's not funny
goddamn song stop play this goddamn song
it's not funny ordered you to execute me
and I'll be damned if I'm gonna stand in
your way
no no no no no no no no no not funny
this crowd they've only come here for
one thing that is to come that is to
watch what is about to happen behind me
in just about a minute's time will it be
spectacular
yes hi I'm Jack Cameron need a new
refrigerator
[Music]
okay all people are degraded they're
full of wisdom and experience time to
kick gum and chew the post on 4chan uses
a profile picture of what appears to be
the Grinch in a mask
holding a gun yeah for old world
government shut down infrastructure
everything to China
[Music]
[Laughter]
was it funny to me kind of a guy I've
been doing great
I've been doing [ __ ] fantastic why
was that the thing that got me in this
very room I need your help can you come
here
I can't I'm buying clothes all right
well hurry up and come over here I can't
find them what do you mean you can't
find them I can't find them there's only
soup what do you mean there's only soup
it means there's only soup well then get
out of there soup aisle I'd like you to
let this yell at me there's more soup
what do you mean there's more soup
there's just more soup going to the next
aisle there's still soup where are you
right now that's so what do you mean
you're at soup I mean I'm at so what
store are you in I'm at the soup store
why are you buying clothes at this
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah I know this one I've seen this
one before [ __ ] classic my god I love
that one
I appear to have invented a
knife-wielding tentacle if anybody would
like to volunteer to come and turn it
off but be just fine
oh [ __ ] all right sky moaned at least
this loud
[Music]
[Laughter]
losing moaning as an example of all the
things that you should do in the in a
storytelling fashion you don't recite
the moan I'm a pioneer I'm an explorer
I'm a human and I'm coming I'm animated
my heart's big I like to eat I like to
fight like the food I like to have
children I got a life force it's got hot
come going through it fast
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
wait no no go away
that guy's a goddamn hero that guy gave
more inspiration than I could ever hope
to give like the best ending I could
have possibly asked for this video I
guess that's it then so you got to do as
he sells you never give up no matter
what just try a little harder try to not
laugh next time because if you did in
this one my god I can't believe you but
there's always next time
so I guess I'll have this one here and
just thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
this one down the comments below I love
doing these it's a lot of work to sift
through the bad ones to get to the funny
but it's always worth it in the end so I
hope you enjoyed it let me know if you
want to see more of this and thanks
again for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye